Niko.
Hi. Long time no see.
Huh?
Who the hell are you?
GENZAN TAIRA
NIKO'S ENEMY, KOEI STYLE
-Now you remember me.
-What are you doing here?
I let him get close.
Oh, I love it.
You've beefed up beautifully
since I last saw you.
You--
I have one thing to tell you.
You've been chasing...
my master for the past ten years
in order to get your revenge.
But I killed him.
How does it feel?
The man who killed your master,
Niko Tokita,
is already dead.
You must be so mad.
Take it all out on me,
the man who stole your revenge.
Come on. Don't be shy.
Go ahead and kill me
just like my master killed Niko Tokita.
I'll see you again someday.
I hope the next time
we see each other...
we'll be enemies.
Niko.
Now, strike me with your anger.
The man who ruined your revenge
is right in front of you.
Don't get the wrong idea.
What did you say?
Revenge?
Did you think that's what I wanted?
Your master and Niko only died
because they were weak.
But I am stronger than Niko was.
The reason I was going after
your master was to prove that.
I can't stand those fools who act like
they're the strongest of all of us.
I'm going to crush
every one of those bastards...
and show them that I'm the strongest!
Luckily, there's a stage set up
for misguided dudes
who think they're the strongest.
I'm going to smash you
at that tournament,
along with all of those other
self-proclaimed "strongest" fighters.
Look forward to it, you freak.
You're right. You're right!
We should choose the best possible stage
on which to kill each other.
Seek for love, fight for love,
and kill each other for love.
And then, in despair of losing you,
I will shoot my load.
Man, you're too much to handle.
Now that we have a plan,
I should get going.
I'll see you at the tournament.
Tell me one thing before you go.
What's your name?
Setsuna.
SETSUNA KIRYU
FIGHTER, KOUOU EDUCATION GROUP
I'm Setsuna Kiryu. Don't forget.
It's the name of your enemy.
Setsuna Kiryu, huh?
Got it.
Setsuna Kiryu!
I'm going to crush you!